Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Soy neurocientífico
y hace años que hago experimentos
para tratar de entender
el comportamiento humano.
Y muchas veces, en este camino,
el cine o la literatura han sido
la única manera de imaginarnos
cómo reaccionaríamos frente
a situaciones extraordinarias.
Desde grandes desamores,
invasiones extraterrestres,
hasta pandemias.
Hasta que la ficción se hizo realidad.
Y aquí y ahora, en casa,
no dejamos de hacernos preguntas.
Desde los rincones más extraordinarios
de la condición humana,
hasta los más ridículos
y los más mundanos.
Por ejemplo, la obsesión mundial
por salir a comprar
montañas de papel higiénico.
Resulta que este comportamiento,
que parece, y es, ridículo
tiene una lógica inconsciente.
En este caso el foco
está más puesto en la intensidad
que en la pertinencia de la respuesta.
Es un poco como el futbolista
que corre desesperadamente una pelota
a la que en realidad
sabe que no va a llegar.
Y es que el fracaso se vive con más alivio
si sabemos que hemos hecho
un gran esfuerzo
para intentar remediarlo.
También es muy propio de lo humano
el tratar de buscar explicaciones
a aquello que nos pasa.
En este caso el gobierno chino,
en solo 10 días,
no solo había encontrado el virus
que producía la enfermedad
sino que había secuenciado
su genoma y lo había hecho público.
Y esto hubiese dado
una gran ventaja de tiempo
al resto de nosotros
de no ser por otro principio
de la psicología humana,
llamado "sesgo optimista".
Lo mismo que hace que muchos de nosotros
manejemos, o conduzcamos,
mientras hablamos por teléfono
o, peor, mientras mandamos mensajes,
pensando que en realidad a nosotros
no nos va a pasar nada.
Esto hizo que
los grandes políticos de Europa
y de muchos otros lugares del mundo
pierdan una gran oportunidad
de actuar a tiempo.
Pero muchas veces
las respuestas que buscamos
no son biológicas o médicas sino
que son más morales o sociales.
¿Por qué nos pasa esto ahora a nosotros?
Y lamentablemente, casi siempre,
estas preguntas terminan
en culpables, o en estigmas.
Por ejemplo, en la peste bubónica
se acusó a los judíos, en Europa,
y a los chinos en San Francisco,
en EE.UU.,
cuando en realidad esto hizo que la gente
pierda una oportunidad
de ver que la ciudad se había convertido
en un cementerio de ratas,
que eran las que realmente
estaban propagando la enfermedad.
En esta pandemia como
en muchas otras
las mascarillas son útiles sobre todo
para evitar que la gente que
ya está enferma contagie a otros.
Sin embargo, en Japón se ha dispuesto
que todo el mundo use mascarillas.
Esto, primero, hace que la gente
que está enferma
y no lo sabe, no contagie.
Esto es muy importante.
Pero además hay otra razón,
quizá más importante,
y es que si solo usasen
mascarillas los enfermos
esto sería como una especie
de cruz acusatoria.
Saber quién está enfermo y quién no
por si usa o no mascarillas.
Que la use todo el mundo
es una manera de evitar el estigma
y, con esto, de cuidarnos a todos.
Quizá lo que más hayamos descubierto
en estos días
es nuestra extraordinaria capacidad
para el cambio.
En general pensamos que persistimos
en nuestras tradiciones,
en nuestros hábitos, en nuestros vicios,
porque es imposible cambiarlos.
Lo cierto es que nos falta motivación
para hacerlo.
Esto lo hemos descubierto ahora.
Durante años pensamos que la educación
no podía cambiar
y que era de aquellas cosas que era
extremadamente difícil de modificar.
Y sin embargo en tres días ahora
todos los chicos se educan en su casa.
No sabemos aún las consecuencias de esto.
Pero sí hemos aprendido
que estamos dispuestos a hacerlo
si la necesidad apremia.
Y el mundo sigue girando.
También, por supuesto, cambian
nuestros valores, nuestros juicios.
Hace apenas dos o tres meses,
cuando empezó la pandemia,
la gente de Occidente miraba a China
con ojos acusatorios
por su predisposición a restringir
las libertades individuales,
a confinar a la gente en sus casas.
Hoy lo que entonces parecía horrible,
que es que todo el mundo
tenga que quedarse en su casa,
nos parece completamente prioritario.
Y sobre esta idea, cómo pueden
cambiar nuestros principios
y cómo podemos ir ajustándolos
me gustaría hacer un pequeño
experimento mental.
Es un dilema, una caricatura, para
que pensemos sobre el futuro.
Imagínense la siguiente situación.
Estamos al principio de la pandemia.
Un consorcio público que incluye
a la Organización Mundial de la Salud,
pero también a gobiernos
y otros sectores públicos
tiene la capacidad a través de alguna
tecnología de saber dónde estamos,
dónde nos movemos, a quién encontramos,
y también datos de nuestra
intimidad corporal.
Nuestra temperatura,
nuestra frecuencia respiratoria,
quizá nuestra carga viral,
y puede usar esa información
para saber quién está infectado
o quién está en riesgo
de estar infectado y quién no.
Supongamos más aún, que este consorcio
puede utilizar esta información
para restringir el movimiento de la gente
de una manera específica.
Aquel que está en riesgo
se queda en casa,
aquel que no está en riesgo puede salir.
Y sigamos en este experimento mental,
imaginando que con esto realmente
atenuamos enormemente
el efecto de la epidemia.
No desaparece completamente
pero se muere muchísimo menos gente
y podemos hacerlo de una manera donde
no tenemos que parar la economía
y el mundo de la manera
que lo hemos hecho.
Por último pensemos que
todas las razones conspirativas
por las que en general
no queremos ceder nuestros datos,
el riesgo a que hagan un mal uso
de ellos, sigue siendo cierto.
No hay nada gratis.
La pregunta es: ¿si estuvieses
al principio de la pandemia,
y pudieses elegir si te parece bien o mal
hacer esto, qué harías?
Elegí este dilema porque creo
que esboza la tensión inevitable
que hay entre, por un lado,
la privacidad y la libertad individual
que son valores fundamentales,
pilares de nuestra cultura.
Y, por el otro lado, las soluciones
colectivas que son necesarias
y las más eficientes
para resolver pandemias.
Quizás ceder nuestros datos
sea un poco como vacunarnos.
Es una concesión que hacemos
de una de nuestras muchas libertades
como parte de un pacto social,
para cuidarnos a nosotros y a todos.
Hace un tiempo, con el HIV,
también hubo una suerte
de jaque a la libertad.
En este caso, a la libertad sexual.
Y encontramos una buena solución
de compromiso:
sexo con preservativo.
Cuando pase todo esto,
¿cuál será el equilibrio
al que querremos llegar
para sentirnos a la vez
libres y cuidados?
¿Acaso van a volar
menos aviones en el cielo?
¿Acaso cambiaremos
la manera de saludarnos?
¿Acaso aceptaremos que está bien
dar partes de nuestros datos
como un bien público
para cuidarnos a todos?
No lo sabemos, pero encerrados en casa
tenemos una oportunidad
para pensar más libremente que nunca
cuál queremos que sea el sexo
con preservativo del coronavirus.